[Music]
oh there we go
all right here we go guys gonna mute
gonna close the chat
and alex just needs to set the clock all
right okay there we go andrea okay eyes
on the goddamn
but i don't know if he's gonna play it
okay
okay the move is d5 let me think
he's gonna know we don't have a lot of
time andrea
yeah i know but this is important alex
okay i i don't know any of this theory
by the way okay so maybe we'll just take
another look should we take yeah take
and then
uh e6 or knight f6 it doesn't have any
threats okay
you look for threads i'm going to think
just this and we're just going to cover
that that's why i like bishop g4 that's
why i like e6 so we can play bishop g4
when he does that
but then we take the knight which i'm
okay with we develop fast do it we've
already lost 30 seconds okay you play
okay i'm too nervous and they can play
queen takes f3 here and win but no okay
that would be should we try this let me
count me
but then he's gonna move the bish okay
and we're gonna have to move the queen
anyway yeah sure sure go for it good
yeah do it dude that's nice yeah that's
all actually our theory should we
obviously oh wait wait a minute though
no no
okay now we need to move our queen or we
take maybe we take uh why don't we move
wait or queen h5 what about queen d7
lock your bishop that that can't be good
no but we're gonna put our bishop this
way
uh okay
right
uh he's only used a second on the clock
by the way uh knight f5
wait uh yeah he has no stack on d5
uh can we do h6
you have to we have to defend that point
we can also do f5 and create a backwards
actually
is much better i would not create that
part like this okay
uh queen e8
yeah that seems wait what is he
threatening
i mean we now we have a lot of fun
i don't know this doesn't look good okay
the time situation is starting to
equalize it looks problematic
but we don't have and by the way we have
a minute on the clock
we need to go 96
no because we lose a piece
i've only spent two seconds which is
kind of good oh
we need to uh we need to play faster but
i think i just blended with your queen
take it out with your queen oh i
couldn't oh i see okay
we need some speed because we have 52
seconds okay
rewrite your night 97
oh bishop g4
i'm just trying to defend things
how are we doing on time 34 seconds
move the king
all right we're good
okay alex is not bad in time pressure
though
yeah
hard to do for 10 games straight okay
this is over
easy peasy lemon squeezy
gotta try
practice your mouse accuracy
yeah
we're even on time okay that's one all
right um okay do you want me to play i
don't know if i'm supposed to click
rematch
they'll just play i guess she'll set it
we don't know the lines yes so i'll play
the london yeah i guess we'll start
thinking wait why are you starting
you need to scooch in a little because i
can't reach the board it's hard for me
to play
so fast yeah we need to get him out of
theory which is literally impossible
andrea we lost 10 seconds already dude
why would you land a system again why
didn't you wait because we were waiting
we'll be fine
we're going to have another hot night
brother five
i need to think okay e5 b4
can i do this
uh okay a3 i'll go probably before
anyone gonna do this and then i take
it's just it looks good do it it doesn't
seem right before
what
i'm gonna do this
i already blundered
okay take his bishop i already blundered
he could go yeah i forgot about that
yeah if i'm gonna have to go there down
a piece yeah but his knights under
attack okay fine just play anything okay
they don't see it
yeah oh and i have 94 maybe okay i'm 94
now
something tells me he knows his lines
something tells me he knew what we
walked into well f f2 is understood to
get lucky on the blunders like queen e3
or something
if that is a fish
yeah he's gonna take and we're gonna
lose we just got we just got danya no we
didn't we're literally equal material
dude don't say we're losing
i like that attitude uh i mean
we can't pretend it's
great but we're not lost no that's a
free pawn
all right knight f3 knight of three the
other night the other night otherwise
we'll get maybe it
yeah queen just trade the queens
trade just train i like this fight oh i
blundered
okay you can have this game and i'll
lead on next game that way we both are
alternating oh blonder one of us will be
able to do it they're good take the rook
take over go we're winning focus
oh d rook d7 rook c7
rookie 7. dude it's a free pawn i know
but we have an attack
the rook c7 other road to d7 do it
i don't andrea i cannot play
you suggest tactics but those were
tactics no
there's no plan behind this
there was but it's fine
should we take
yeah
11 seconds is a lot of time for him
i mean it doesn't matter it's already
lost
okay
it looks like i pulled it
actually let's just try
maybe i'm giving him too much credit for
being so good
probably not though there we
i can't deal with alternate plans
because i can't think for myself then so
if somebody's playing on time pressure
tactics i gave you there was one that
four seconds of despair
it wasn't it was it wasn't the time and
you're nice check
they don't have a line against your
plans we could have won whatever just
i'm not going to suggest things
you tell them okay if you want me to be
completely silent while you're playing
no completely no no
we can alternate who's playing and i
think we just suggest them when they're
when we're very sure i was very sure
arguing nice we just got to sew the
seeds in you know
discord
thank you that flow 8182.
i was saying that i cannot think
so
thank you anna school if you would like
to play
it's fine just if you want me to be
silently playing i'll be silent i'm not
saying yeah in fighting okay sure next
time okay but i don't have much time
though so we gotta start the next year
very slowly
but if you want i'll just do the moves
yes that's what i would like it was the
best move in the position i would like
to do it
it's not an argument let's not argue
pull up the evaluation because everyone
in chat said it was the best move yeah
and they've said that before and they've
been wrong they're like fall under his
plan
against ben and then we lost chat
literally is 1300. stop using the free
arguments gerber and sanguine who are
actually 1900
oh fake
take on h3 at least
he has 25 seconds just try
h6
is under attack
oh they took it
okay
oh crap that was bad i don't know why i
did that
what
an unnecessarily unnecessary move
i mean it's still completely winning
96.
the idea is
uh 28 well it's it it's probably lost
regardless
try you try bishop v8
okay i guess i'll just lift my real cup
i mean
yeah that works maybe you're working
then
oh okay bishop e8 rookie three and then
rook have three
okay this should be this should be
winning
yes knight c6 defend e7
he's gonna
not make it yet though
he has 20 seconds you're gonna try no
they won't die
try getting him to trade queen e5
yeah but we're gonna lose this
he's just gonna promote like i'm there's
nothing i can yeah
yeah okay this is over there
there's not a shuffle there's no this is
disrespectful
you could steal me
walk into a trap
well
oh they forked me
okay
all right all right
i'm trying to think what that's true
there's no such thing as disrespect in a
30-second match i agree yeah kavita it's
it they do have three minutes no i i
wasn't but i i guess you're joking i was
just making sure because you might have
joined when andrea resigned
like with eight seconds and all those
pawns yeah again somebody started that i
mean at least i would play that but okay
i'm playing well let's just play
openings problem is i need to win 10
games i was thinking out of the book and
i just don't know what i'm doing but
maybe it's better okay are you playing
white before you change the clock that's
that's that's problematic
ooh they played c4 okay
that was a bad move
i meant to play c5
why not okay
now it's transposed back to theory i
like c5 better
yeah i don't like this though
he's coming with g4
or i could push h3 yeah video you'll
just grade five yeah but i haven't cast
g no
i was thinking g4 to block the attack if
we take something from the bishop
attack on his queen
i don't think we should open up our king
side
uh we could push here or we could take
um you don't have to take it right away
we have to push
i like b5
with what goal though
with what threat to go c6 well what if
we just block the entire position so
we're also getting our other pawn in
actually you could go c6
yes
also i don't think we should play for a
draw because that'll make us play worse
take
well at least our king isn't there
um
i think we just leave it although our
role maybe king walks walks the king to
c2
and then you could try
i mean you're not going to castle
anymore
well why do we need to move it
well it's only if we're not going to
connect our bishop's going to come on
so if we if we put our if the plan is
for bishop you won then i think
yeah we needed to call something on here
but can't we play queen here and then
give him checks no that's a free queen
you mean queen of three no cake here
queen here he takes we give some checks
yeah
yeah that's good
nice
now they're perpetual
i have to get mated because i i should
have asked for a draw at least use the
bishop
queen
here that he can't get out
go back to e8 go back don't eat no eat
cause he can push the pawn
we have 22 seconds by the way okay wait
i might have escaped
he's going to push we have any other
checks maybe just queen h4 okay
oh that
that was
i mean that was like a magician's act
i don't know how i escaped those checks
i mean it was like
no because i think the only way i waited
yeah
yeah that was the houdini that was the
houdini act
there was one moment for bishop e3
otherwise i don't think he had it well
bishop d3 he's still happy yeah there
was with the queen's defense oh yeah
that was the only chance right otherwise
four zero wait oh yeah six more to go oh
yeah there was one time which i said the
black games are really really really
tough because their wide openings are
pretty good same-ish
and the london i mean it's just hard to
crack with 30 seconds
with why they can get like
pretty tactical position really really
quickly
he has four points we don't want to win
right away
oh this is okay
very fast
i think i'm gonna go knight a5 i
think let's see
knight d5
i'm gonna take it and go bishop e6
probably oh b6 again
i know you're going to fall for oh we
missed this again
the same trick
okay well
yeah okay i'm going to do this
rook c8 i guess
if i take just play queen g4 i have 95
which is good okay now i take it and i
go 95 and i think i forced the queen
trade
i think they forced the queen trade
yeah this is good nothing i mean they
can take on h3 but then i take the want
to bring the bishop in it's a better
piece
and then do we want to take on each
other now i should be able to win this
pretty easily yeah just gonna simplify
god damn it can't believe i fell for
that twice
yeah just making me just try faster
i know
[Music]
halfway there
yeah i should honestly okay we should
slow down in the opening
i was trying to be too fast for no
reason
okay so what do i play
there's another line
guessing in the castle
and then
i hope they go clean you can play
like queen f4
do you think we can take
let me calculate no because i think with
check
take t we can also just play bishop e3
let me grab
this but it's probably better to defend
bishop g3 baby what about this sure
okay i'm gonna try to get to c2
rookie one rookie one we don't want to
let him push uh wait uh okay just make
sure not to allow a bishop c3
bishop a pusher pawn no no no no no do
that
wait king of one
he's gonna play here
i was thinking about rook d8 but then
they'll get bishop
yeah we can't get the bishop here unless
okay
let's only say moves a lot because i
can't think otherwise
g4
i thought about it but he just moved his
bishop back and i don't think we did it
bishop b3 and then you start attacking
pawn
and then rookie three and then true if
you feel confident about it
oh yeah that's a free bishop that's why
we can't do it you could take the oh no
we'll get pinned
and this should be easy
yeah
we didn't have it i mean it doesn't
matter
there's no stalemate
be careful
probably
oh okay sorry i i've been honestly
throwing i feel like i shouldn't even
accommodate
you can just say it when you're
confident yeah i know i am easy
plenty of times you want to play your
sicilian again yeah i do i'm not going
to fall for the same trap easy clap all
right let's go
i'm going to play a little slower
no oh they took the queen oh no
oh you didn't take my knight oh my god
okay my night was literally hanging and
i ugh
i'm discombobulated i need to get all
right focus focus focus everything's
good
a4
not blunder anything
else shut it down shut it down ah they
got to have five in time
yeah okay
take take
i would just move the knight back
no because then he gets knight g5 and
his queen is closer to our king i don't
think yeah we're good we're good
everything's in seven also defends up
seven
double yeah unless there's a tactic
where he can take stuff
on and then
it's fine i think
i could take a double as pawns no i
would just play rooks no don't do that
don't give him the open h foul
he's baiting brook here sure
uh
or or queen b5 so we can play queen b8
just make a waiting or we're getting low
on the clock by the way
um
run from that
hopefully our king has some ideas
oh god
the fact that he's playing this well
with
he didn't even use 30 seconds in puzzle
rush insane
okay let's try again
no too easy yeah i'm going to play the
london wait okay let's go we need
something i kind of i kind of like you
got to give me something more than that
if you feel confident sure how many
games we only have three games left we
need to be strategic okay yeah so i'll
play this one and you can get london in
the last one
okay
um
you took me to sleep on last time but i
oh no
this is not a real move
but i'm trying to milk some clock time
after o'clock
you
can't push
can you just make it so that's why it's
gonna be hard to no you're gonna lose
your potting
and then you're gonna lose your s on an
e4 it doesn't matter we're up
we can give you i'm not just fish hooky
too right now
what about take and push
you're gonna lose that pawn right it
doesn't matter we're up upon why don't
we just we're we're allowed to lose
i don't think this is good but if you
feel strongly about it then i'll do it
because we're gonna have the same issues
we had last time okay i think they're
gonna take my knife your queen is
defended okay what would you play here
go ahead with the knight or the pawn let
me think
you could take the knight of the pawn
either work honestly knight because if
he takes back with the knight you just
take it and then our king is going to be
stuck in the center which is why this is
not okay if they capitalize
yeah
probably the bishop i don't know these
lines i know that's why
okay so you have to do the knight you
don't have choice
okay just focus
i'm gonna
i i uh i know why it's turning off but
it's gonna keep starting why not rookie
one
i'm pretty sure we just lose this
okay we have 54 seconds um
only say a move if you're sure of it
what what is the plan with rook do you
want
i have 40 seconds
i take the rook and then the bishop the
bishop was protected i mean i'll tell
you i had a million winning moves there
are we sure we don't want to just this
is
why don't we just why don't we all just
relax i'm relaxed i'm relaxed
yeah 92
let's let's see it 92
nope
can literally take my time here oh
there's a blunder
bang
sorry i i i know i'm throwing because
i'm not two more guys
openings
maybe we tried i was pulling out my lawn
chair there the lead in the opening
because we can't get this i was
literally pulling out my car straight
so how
about i'll play the opening
well
the sicilian has been kind of rough
because
i've given him a rook twice in a row do
we want to go i don't know
i'm not in the mood
to go for it
and i'll keep an eye on time i ain't in
the mood to dance i'm sorry
was bad because not today
not today i mean also he's just playing
he's just playing really well so
um do you think french is better
uh
i don't know but we could try something
different i okay i want to try because
the thing is he he's he knows are they
arguing like it might be interesting to
just try a different opening
i just need two more games
do anything stupid
and if i do do something stupid the key
is to recover immediately i'm gonna try
my sicilian
all right i'm gonna just keep an eye for
tactics i'm gonna be a little slower
take over at one minute
it's
this time i'm gonna go play correctly
i'm gonna win their knight on h6
i'm gonna go b6 and bishop a6
i think maybe i wasn't supposed to allow
that
what about f5 you have to go king h8
here with black um and i'll give you
that takes them somewhere he doesn't
have a threat oh no he's gonna uh
something's wrong wait wait let me think
there i need to get him out i need to
get out of this
it is he takes doesn't yeah okay bishop
g5 isn't better unless i think of the
rook
can't you just keep going on the queen
side he doesn't actually have he's going
to do this and this yeah that's the
threat and then i'm going to lose my
knight
well you can play king h8 after if he
does that
okay i'm just going to make a move the
idea once he does this okay now and i
could do this because if he takes takes
push push i take here actually bishop a6
i should go queen b2 no now we're going
to lose the knight because otherwise
they might go king k
right away
now their knight is trapped
you might as well attack his king okay
the plan here is to go king ju
okay
does this aggressive too aggressive
yeah i wouldn't know the portion that i
come here and then i go to f5
queen fade i have bishop f4 if you feel
it's strong bishop f4 brooks
yeah we're a long time so you have to
play mostly off of intuition i don't
yeah exactly
pressure but it's okay
i would not take or maybe with my rook
yeah move your rook and try to get rid
of his knife although that's going to
block it
oh it's fine
hey bishop e5 bishop f8 nothing
okay
okay we're chilling we're totally
chilling here
totally chilling
i take the knight he takes the rook
see that he takes the rook
i have no
well you have 30 seconds so just move my
intuition bring your other rook in time
situation is equal
i think we're good no i'm gonna get made
like you need to try something because
you have you have less time than him now
so just the practice of making rook c7
just practice making moves
take it oh you can't get it oh that's
freaking queen e7
uh take his queen with check
and then take the bishop okay go this is
good i can't i have nine seconds i'm i'm
being fed down apparently all right
material so
i thought we had one material i'm so out
of it okay and we have no time
all right your turn sister i i don't
know where the confidence came from i
thought we were up a piece
it's impossible
i give up and the last game goes there's
literally no chance again i haven't
finished this in style he's too strong
and he's too fast he hasn't gone down to
the clock
style i thought we were winning i
thought i didn't realize we were already
down material that was okay i also
didn't realize how much i'm at on the
clock what's it like down there in the
carolinas it's good
it's i just don't know anymore okay i
know what i choke this now you're sure
yeah i'm just not really upset
clothesline one that was our best chance
and i'm gonna do it uh i almost gave
myself thursday and give yourself more
time after this because you're wasting
time to do it yeah
give yourself 30.
okay last game guys
okay you're sure you know what you're
gonna play yes
i'm gonna play the more clothesline
do it
[Music]
play accelerate the dragon structure
b4
i don't want to leave anything on the
long diagonal bishop
i'd rather
reroute bishop before it was doing
you're attacking me
focus not on what is wrong with the
position because that doesn't help me
what about this
i'm just gonna try he plays so fast
oh
is this not winning no let's just take
our time i think it's winning because he
doesn't have any checks no he has to
take
yeah it's winning holy [ __ ] i got mated
oh my god down to the wire baby oh
now you get to see the gm dance
unbelievable
you can't be yeah you can't yeah
but then again he literally just swept
the floor with us so i
i feel bad that he's sad but i feel
happy that i mean he literally destroyed
us like
like every other we stood literally
anyway but he's still gonna dance
he missed one tiny tactic and just swept
the floor with us in every other single
game
i was not expecting to have to do this
should we just pull it
okay you don't have to you know
he looks like he's gonna cry
no don't say you don't have to that's
even worse that's even worse
you're saying i should do
oh god
he
looks i just cannot believe i i've
choked the last game i honestly cannot
believe it
but uh
no i gotta do it i agreed to it sorry i
was not actually upset i was just trying
to work out
okay i think we're good wait now i have
to look at myself which is the most
embarrassing part
it looked like he was about let me put
this what happened wait does is he gonna
is this gonna be the cam angle the
entire time
he outsmarted us in the end andrea
i mean surely he knows the camera angle
and sees season
oh my god and it's emote only so now let
me pause can you guys see me
yes you guys can see me
[Music]
this motion i'm pretty comfortable with
fantastic workout
all right plus applause from the
audience please well that's that's what
we get
oh my god i want to see what is look not
all farmers are made equal checks it's
actually harder than it seems to do that
for four minutes
it honestly is thank you for watching
thank you very much i want to see if
anyone if he's ever to realize thank you
to alex and andrea for not making me do
something embarrassing that was of
course quite dignified
we would never this is not the first
time i'm dancing on stream i've done it
before
i feel like the last time was
significantly more
i don't know
i think the last time it is saying good
afternoon oh stress of the five subs
thank you why are you saying good effort
i was already i tasted i was tasting
victory you know well it was a good
effort so the 20 subs were unnecessary
but i really really appreciate it
okay i said thanks for the match that
was fun
okay i guess that was a lot of fun i'm
always down for that
[Music]
you